tesla is back elon musk is promoting a
new invention that looks a lot like you
and me you're looking at his plans for a
humanoid robot called teslabot musk
expects a prototype to be ready by next
year he hopes that one day the bot will
be able to do repetitive and boring jobs
for you like picking up groceries sign
me up the tesla bot has some stiff
competition in the humanoid robot
department boston dynamics atlas robot
debuted in 2013 and on wednesday we
showed you a video of that robot nailing
an obstacle course
yeah this one has a head got a hand but
it's got a head i do like that it has a
head i do like that i love that musk
promises that his his robot will be a
benign presence he also says just in
case you can run away from it and most
likely overpower it yeah what does that
mean that's frightening because the
other robot the boston dynamics robots
scare the hell out of yeah i'm not
messing with them i want to know if this
robot washes baby bottles and sue's baby
is waking up is that a job you don't
want to do
i'm happy to do it in the middle of the
night i get it the bottle washing i
could do with that i get it pretty
remarkable we'll see if this robot comes
to fruition i think we hear a lot of
ideas from elon musk so we have to wait
ellen always thinks outside the box and
i like that apparently it's five foot in
five foot eight and weighs 125 pounds
can lift 45 pounds um and like you said
run i weighed 125 pounds in fourth break
right